so this is candy streets Bom Bom oh I
will watch the show and I know that
sound I don't watch the show okay it's
born child shows are boring to me okay
cop shows are foreign to me they're all
boring so I thought this episode's
cowboy no no okay a judge uh I thought
this was fine I I you know what was the
one one last job I liked a little bit
more I know it's we're comparing them
but they are sort of like the you know
hit the streets crime stories though
that was more of a heist story and this
is more you know well is from the
criminal and this is more from the
detective and and lumpy Space Princess
comes in screaming and yelling about
something and people's puts this great
big syringe into her and she starts
garbling something say piece size of I
and max out so Finn and Jake are on the
case and decide really quick um yeah
right after she said that like within
half a minute like everyone hears like
yeah they're like sorry go ahead
what that's kind of like yeah go on
so yeah so we all knew what that was got
the paper the most part but we thought
like she was gonna be like just full-on
pizza or something but they you know
like she just a stomach ache oh my god
she's a drama queen you know that's just
I don't know yeah I thought but no it's
a well can we get to that second so Finn
and Jake are on the case they're going
around they're trying to be all
detective ii jake has a serious problem
turning into all these cop things these
items and stuff and he can't stop and
they don't even help in fact they make
things worse I can't write down anything
that was great though I love with it
every time the pencil came down you know
I had just cute little faces like II he
and then when he finally bug to me he's
like yeah and so they think it's this
guy called Pete Sassafrass and it turns
out they
they put him in jail it turns out it's
not him
and that actually lucky space princess
was just obsessed with this delivery boy
and he just wanted to get away because
she's insane and then they turned into a
car go out the window and the guy
presumably rots in jail for the rest of
his days voiced by Jim Cummings which
who plays the character yeah I thought
that was really funny and I'm I don't
like to bet that was intentional you
know I was saying to myself like I don't
know it's a bit of a stretch but no I
because you can see them talking about
he isn't it weird that you're playing a
guy named Pete it's like I can't see
them being like you know yeah what a
coincidence like I think that was kind
of intentional if I hadn't guessed
because he is like the official voice of
Pete you know so that's my guess Oh
every single Pete on the planet he
voices Pete and Pete done by him yeah
yeah doesn't it by the way I love that
show incredible awesome um so anywho um
and I felt like the first half of the
show I was I feel so weird saying first
half cuz it's only 11 minutes long
you're robbing me five minutes on first
five and a half minutes yeah but is sure
I do like the first half a lot more and
then like I started to get a little
tired of the detective thing I don't
know maybe it's kind of like mage is not
my love of detective cop stories you
know I just never got that into it but I
mean it's it's in the fan we got the
twist our way you know but it's it's
still fine um and it was fun I loved
seeing Jake turn into all those things I
like seeing him turn into the lawyer any
time he turns into this any time he just
turns up to anything I it always gets a
laugh out of me because it's always like
just so extreme it's so strange and it
totally messes up with you know making
sense or continuity because there's a
million times where they get into like
trouble where it's like we can change
into anything you can get out of this um
but to me does America's it leads to
more cool scenes where he just
changes into stuff a lot of different
ways he gets him into the car like he'll
have his what he them and then throw
down and stuff and yeah I mean that made
me laugh I like the ice cream cone just
going to this incredible detail about
this person that came in knows
everything like except the name and it's
not like remembers my name - so that's
what always honestly bothers me about a
lot of the cop shows is that two years
ago blank happened do you remember that
of course I do I remember everything and
I'm like most people say I can't
remember what I had for breakfast but I
have a feeling most people can't
remember what they did you know a week
beforehand much less remember all that
stuff in detail and I think obviously
that's what they were going for there
she's oh yeah no I can't help you in any
way
wait a minute yeah I'm like I love that
poking fun at that yeah yeah yeah I
think in that crazy when people just
talk during the V log it's very rude
yeah I know I agree
even else so yeah I thought was fine I
thought it was fine it was okay again
figuring out the plot but then again I
mean honestly for me watching Law &
Order
Jory went through a law-and-order kick
where I literally had on my playstation
the sound clip
dum-dum and I would play that everyone
surrounding joy it was so Pavlovian
joyous like like expected but upon
watching enough episodes of it you kind
of figure out exactly what's gonna
happen you figure out all the plot
twists one of my favorite things is
Robot Chicken did an episode where it's
all chickens
buk buk buk buk buk buk my entire
episode of Law & Order with nothing but
chickens going buk buk buk and you know
exactly what was going on was an April
Fool's episode no that would have been a
great just second but that was you know
kind of like this is like were they
poking fun at it in the sense of it's so
easy to figure out what the plot twist
is or were they trying to be clever and
just kind of failing you know or are we
just super awesome and we figured it out
because we're awesome that's me though I
I was kind of let down by that I did
love BMO I'm sorry BMO going around you
know circling evidence and then and then
a hand on the wall with you just know
your keys denigan for me BMO's always
been like I always can make an episode
for me I love the LSP sweatshirt that
obviously is just LSP yeah I like there
are bags everywhere Thanks and wait
those are her dresses I did like I just
like take being like I have a problem
and then a little bit later on no I
really have a problem I'm gonna help
anybody just like what my first one he
Finn has the binoculars then she puts
binoculars a fry him and then she grabs
the binoculars so for an episode we
think is okay we're naming a lot of
really funny moments I'm a Beema Beema
like the door was it like the door yeah
the door be taped back up and then just
a break it again I like them going
through the window again which had you
don't even see any like I you just
presumably the guy do window I guess I
well what it's not you're gonna tape up
glass I know you taped up a door yeah
cuz that's wood well plenty on tape
glass when they kick it have you not
heard the sound effects for kicking down
let me go kick down the door